yeah i gotta watch my you were my second
comedy show ever i used to
literally watch your videos all the time
where did you see that from uh
stand up live yeah oh you're out of
arizona yeah stand up live
it barely had open i think you were like
yeah there was a one first you were one
of the first ones uh how long ago is
this
chappelle man this had to be like 2011.
chapelle used to work you know across
the street where they put all the stand
the comics at the hotel
he used to work valet there i used to
work valet at the palomar wow
he saw bill burr there and bill burr let
him do a spot yeah during the shows
i was helping him with his luggage and
parked his car and stephanie
that's still he's like you want to go up
and i was like oh [ __ ] yeah that's cool
isn't that cool yeah it was pretty cool
and yeah so yeah i
used to watch your videos all the time
so like this one like you talk about
your moments this is like
one of those moments for me like sitting
here with you
yeah it's it's so cool i'm like oh
decoys right here
so how about that jeep
you were the comedian that like you know
because i would watch so much of it just
to try to understand it because
all i really knew was like eddie murphy
raw dave chappelle's killing him softly
but like i thought those were i didn't
think those were things like anybody
could just do
you know like anybody could like you
know go and work at it and then
like when i started it and you know
trying to find my way
you know i saw you and i was like man
this guy does something with his
performance that's just so
different than like most you know what i
mean some people were just kind of like
you like give uh uh a show
you know which is like yeah because
there's i mean you know what i'm talking
about stuff
but people like what they just
i love it man thank you i appreciate
that i love that
yeah it knows like a good but joe's a
good guy
for uh younger comics to try to model
their courage
you gotta realize he was handing out
flyers in vegas
yes while he was working at nordstrom's
rack while he was doing all this stuff
and then now he's one of the biggest
biggest comics in the world and i i
learned so many lessons from john you
know i'm not trying to suck you off on
the show here but
uh but also he does all the press
yeah i made it yeah okay okay okay cool
cool
i'm cool all right cool cool
i remember the show it was you michael
yeone orlando baxter
wow yeah holy [ __ ] that's a long time
ago i remember it clearly
wow dude i i even made sure i got there
early to sit up front
because i would literally watch your
video huh that's why you're still doing
club yeah man
that stand up live was new too and i
think you already had your special out
um tommy said yeah on comedy central i
think you already had uh
when you talked about something in
alabama where they're like you like come
through the window
yeah come to the window yeah i remember
yeah i love that joke you know where
that joke came from
where i was in alabama i was i was on
this black comedy college
tour it's called black college comedy
tour it and i was opening
for uh i think that i it was
i think that was michael blackson that
night and uh
so they you know they always send a
student to pick you up right
and uh and they were driving we were
driving to the venue this [ __ ] is
in the cut i think it's called i don't
know the name of it what city it was but
it's just very rural right yeah is that
how you rule
and we're driving and he looks at me
he's like man
how is it on uh on comic view
like you guys look like you have fun
every day and i'm like in my head i'm
like
i shot that 10 years ago oh damn i know
i'm like oh i mean it was fun but i mean
i was only one
i did it one night and i was done he
goes oh what
that's not every night i watch it every
night i'm like those are
reruns
and you can tell by the clothing we're
wearing
it's not currently but he was for real
like
and that's where that little alabama
campaign is hilarious because it was
just this
[ __ ] wow
so when you leave here you go back
television right like
no man what was it called re-run
i'm sure okay man we rerun my man oh
man we stopped that came from it's
hilarious
it was that in your your little set i
think it was leno right yeah
that was like these those big old school
yeah you wanna know how gangster leno is
so i was doing by the way i'm working at
nordstrom rack
doing leno right i got that i got i got
leno on uh
uh montreal right so when i walked off
of new faces
uh ross and bob walked up to me they
were the bookers and they were like
save that set for the tonight show we're
going to put you on
so damn game changer for me especially
back then especially
back then and i remember everyone was
like oh you just got this nice show
that's good tape it's not really going
to do anything i remember all the
comments were saying that to me right
but i was like dude i need this right so
anyways uh
i'm backstage i got my dad and i got my
sisters
and we're backstage and jay's like uh
oh they they told me they wore me first
producers came don't curse
this is live we're taping live don't
curse please if you curse we have to cut
your
we have to cut it i promise i won't and
they go just go over your
your cue cards make sure you say it word
for word stay right on it
and just right at the end just say good
night and stand on your mark
right that's another story by the way me
standing on the mark anyways
i go all right no problem and then j
blocks in he's got his
denim outfit on and he's like hey man uh
nice to meet you tomorrow
like uh so uh we're excited to have you
on and uh
i can't wait and uh you know here's the
thing
i know they talk i know they told you
that not cursed but uh
go ahead curse you oh you know if he
cares don't worry about it
you know uh you know we tape you know so
i don't want you to stress out it's your
first time on the show
accidents happen you curse we'll cut it
up all right so
that's magic of hollywood all right so
don't worry about it it's your first
time
just uh enjoy relax kill yourself right
joe
oh my god thank you so much uh jay love
you hug him
then he's walking down the hallway and
he turns back around he goes hey uh
joe i go what he goes don't [ __ ]
curse
yo he got me so good man i thought he
was serious that's hilarious he sold it
so good
he's a clean comment yeah because at all
yeah
don't [ __ ] curse don't [ __ ] curse
you know what's crazy about jay leno is
every
damn near every sunday he's at the
malibu market because there's a car show
there
yeah and he you know he's the biggest
car guy in the world and he brings like
these exclusive cars there all the time
and
fans around him asking him questions and
there's this i was there and there's
this little kid
who you know he doesn't know the rules
and i mean jay pulled up and
i don't know this two million dollar old
school lamborghini yeah and this kid is
just
touching it and now i'm like oh [ __ ]
this ain't good and jay season he goes
hey hey little man and i was like oh
[ __ ] he's gonna scroll him goes
you like the car and he's like yeah kiss
like bright orange he goes once you sit
in it opens the car door
lets the kid [ __ ] mess with all the
buttons and everything i'm like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah he's really that dude yeah he's a
great guy yeah man
okay so joaquin was it joaquin phoenix
is that anything walking faster yeah
right yeah
the one that didn't walk in the joke
oh walk the line walk the line
yeah okay so oh yeah yeah so he was on
he was uh
he was on he was on uh my episode right
at the tonight show
and uh and they were like hey
this is when he was acting weird
remember he wanted to be a rapper he was
wearing the black glasses
but he's so [ __ ] weird kind of an act
right
we don't know it was so [ __ ] weird
and he was just doing that whole like
like flinching and stuff he had his
glasses like tweaking out but he wasn't
we didn't know what was going on he was
in his green room
and uh and they walked up to me and they
were like hey uh
we just got word that he's not feeling
good and so uh
we need like two extra questions for jay
to ask you
because we need you to sit at the uh at
the couch longer
because he's got to leave he's not
feeling good at all
i'm like because he was like tweaking i
was like oh [ __ ]
i felt bad but i was like [ __ ] yeah man
but also like
leave now [ __ ] right like let me
do the whole show
and then uh so anyways cut two he's he's
getting interviewed
the [ __ ] goes long he walks
all into my time he goes into another
segment he goes he walks in the
commercial break
then ross and bob run up to me like look
man we're so sorry about this
we got to cut your time right so they
cut my time
and uh and you can't walk to the couch
because we have no time for you to go to
the couch
hey walking sticks yeah the [ __ ] i know
he went so long and i was even like yo
he's going like
real long like i remember we were
watching like what the [ __ ] this dude is
talking you're doing time
right and then uh so so they go just
stand on your mark
just stand on your mark and jay's gonna
run up to you and say your name and then
you guys are gonna both wave to the
camera that's gonna be the end of the
show
i was like all right [ __ ] i was so mad
because i wanted to sit on a couch man
yeah and i remember backstage i was
jumping i was about to go on
i was jumping and the two security cars
were jumping and they're like you ready
i was like i can't wait for this [ __ ]
moment getting hyped
yeah and i walked out i [ __ ] crushed
right
i got the standing o and i'm standing at
my mark right
and then you see me look because i'm
waiting and he keeps and he's [ __ ]
jay's like get the [ __ ] off
get the [ __ ] oh so i run to the couch
and he does a setup question real quick
just ask me a quick question and then we
go to break
i don't know i'm so sorry jay they told
me i had to stand on the mark man
um i didn't know what to do that's why i
was standing there he was like no no no
it's okay man man you guys standing oh i
never got a [ __ ] stand
how many times i did the tonight show
now one [ __ ] thing
he goes i had to call you over man
come over here and then he called my
family
oh and brought him on stage in front of
the entire audience what
and took pictures of yo that dude was
such a classic man
he had dirt he had dirt all underneath
his fingernails all different
yeah he goes yeah i was like yo why your
head because he was [ __ ] his hands
were [ __ ] dirty i go
why are you so dirty and he goes uh he
goes yeah my [ __ ] car
is breaking down on the way here i had
to like tune it up on the way
man did you ever see joaquin phoenix
complete dick move to run over on his
time do you ever see him on a
letterman and he's playing that
character and dave's like just like what
the [ __ ] dude
and he's not even known and dave keeps
going at him like dave's relentless yeah
like he's not backing down dave just
keeps [ __ ] pushing him pushing him
yeah and like joaquin phoenix is just uh
he doesn't want to talk
dave's like really dave's like i'm glad
you came on the show this is cool man
and he's just like hmm he's like yeah
right on and then dave just keeps
[ __ ] pushing him
it's a great moment yeah dave's such a
beast but there's no show like that now
right like
if you get it like that changed my life
it really did especially back then like
it was such a big deal it was huge
before i was working at nordstrom rack
every other person that i got a shoe for
saw me on the tonight can i get a size
eight and a half oh my god you were so
funny on and like
now like but before leno and letterman
there was
carson right carson made everybody's
career yeah you got a carson like
everybody would have four minutes like
let's try and crush carson
yeah man i went to leno and letterman
and then now there's like
you know conan's giving some comics or
kimmel's giving some comics sometime but
it's like
it's just gonna go on youtube yeah it's
really not like it's not launching
you know what i always said was kind of
like uh a carson
uh like if if you got the okay from like
carson you you moved on
chelsea handler was the same way yes man
i i'm telling you dude anyone that
killed on chelsea
your career just took off that show was
so it was huge
i can't even explain watch it all the
time handler was so big she was big
dude crushed she dated 50.
yeah yeah yeah she did all right
very good
i did handler i think it was her last
year or second last year
and i was so excited to do the show but
then she was sick and whitney
coming from oh whitney did it yeah nice
co-hosted yeah
that was so much fun man chelsea was
great she was she was [ __ ] great
talented lady yeah man she changed you
know she i was supposed to be
like chewy i was supposed to be oh
really yeah
because we opened did i tell you this
story so uh we used to open am i talking
too much no no no
so i was uh it was i was opening for
john lovitz right
john was like i every wednesday at the
lab factory was john lovitz it was
called john lovitz wednesday or some
[ __ ] or aloha wednesdays or some [ __ ]
and uh and he he was like um i get it
i'm gonna bring a female comic her name
is chelsea
handler she's hysterical
she's my only friend on myspace
and i went home and i checked myspace
and it was tom and chelsea handler
that's all he followed and then all of a
sudden she started coming to the shows
and uh and she would like go up you know
she would open right she wasn't a big
name at all at the time no
no one knew her yeah and then so we
would sit uh
and watch john and she would just you
know how she is
she's [ __ ] hammering you know i mean
she's just like
she's just making fun of anybody and
then uh so she uh
she looks at me and she's like i got
this show idea
and uh we're gonna make it and i want
you to be my my side
oh wow so we started going to like
meetings and [ __ ] right and then uh
she was like you'll be my like you
you'll be my uh my guy on the side like
i'll make fun of you and and then
like if we do man on the street we'll
send you and like it'll be so funny
it'll be so
so good and i'm like all right cool and
we started coming up with ideas
and then all of a sudden i get uh i get
like this uh
deal not it wasn't really a deal it was
kind of like i got my hour special
and uh and they they were kind of like
talking about doing a show with me so i
turned her down
oh damn yeah right i turned her down
and i called her and i go hey chelsea
i'm not gonna i'm gonna go ahead and
move
away from this project because i want to
work on this project i don't think yeah
i don't know where it will go but
they're interested and she cursed me out
right she was like oh
savage yeah like cursed me man i wish i
recorded it man it was like
you're gonna make you made the worst
[ __ ] decision this show is gonna be a
[ __ ] hit
good luck with your [ __ ] career
this is the worst decision you've ever
[ __ ] made i swear to god
maybe you should listen to your agent
sometimes why don't you listen to your
[ __ ] gut
you're making the worst [ __ ] and i'm
like chelsea chelsea
and then i'll bet i'm six months later
i'm at
nordstrom wreck and my ex-wife comes to
pick me up and we're driving home and
she's like
have you heard of this chelsea handler
she's so
funny i'm recording it right now and i'm
just like
[ __ ] me i smell like nikes
i'm watching this i'm like then i see
chewie i'm like that's supposed to be
chewy chewy but then she called me she
called me like you know like a month
later
on the show oh she put me on like once
a month and then it went to twice a
month and then it went to four times a
month
like people thought i was one of the
writers but she just she's
she loved you if she if you were funny
she loved you yeah she put you on so how
long after
leno cause you said you were working at
north yeah so how long after that after
leno
did you like work didn't have to work
that job after leno i got a commercial
for amp mobile they used to sponsor
the ufc that's how i got to see hoist
fight uh
matt and um and uh
i got a commercial deal right after the
tonight show
damn and they paid me fat this guy's
dude this guy was from australia or some
[ __ ]
he had so much money and he was like uh
i'll pay this much a show
uh we go and uh uh we go and uh
god i don't even know what i'm saying
right no he just
right off the tonight show and what he
did is he was doing like these
uh he would get a bunch of people that
sell phones
to come and he would entertain them
before he would introduce the new phone
that he's trying to get them to sell
so he would have like dancers a comedian
all that
and he made me close these shows and he
would pay me
fat bro like he would pay me so fast
eight shows i was like dude i don't need
to work for like two years
then he gave me the commercial so then
did you call nordstrom rec did you go in
or like i'm out yeah
yeah no not i just i was like but they
all knew because i was doing stand up
there
so they all knew like if something
happened i was gonna i was gonna bounce
i can tell you it was like customers to
get shoes from bro yeah
because it's the one where it's not
nordstrom it's nordstrom rack
it's the one where they all the shoes
are on the floor so you're looking for a
matching third
so they give you one and then you go to
the back and i'm supposed to find the
other one
it's like dude i would never [ __ ]
look for it it's a nightmare
i would never look for it i would just
come back and i go someone must have
tried it on it's out there somewhere if
you want to look good
you don't worry i would i would do it
all the time i swear to god i go yo
uh someone tried this on obviously
because it's not back there because it's
so neatly
nice by the way what you see out there
it looked just like that in the back it
was so bad
yes it would say yeah it would just be
like size eight heels it would be all
black heels
yeah so if you got a black heel and an
eight you would just go to this bin that
said
eight heels and you had to like dig
through and i can only imagine
the one by lax was just like that was
the worst one
yeah the worst one damn damn how about
that when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like you look like a rottweiler
you gotta [ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son